At that time, I thought that the whole world was my enemy.
It's hard for anyone to say "I can't see
you" So that's why I keep my eyes down and close my ears I'm
sure there's a friend who has the same feelings as you as a qualification
From the moment I spoke to you like this, you weren't alone anymore It's
time  If you do, you'll forget me
But I'll never forget how I forced myself to meet you and understand each other
Whenever you feel anxious or lonely Come back to this place
[music]
[applause]
rar It's
definitely the same sound as I thought at the cafe There are friends who have lost their strength
So they won't cry because of me
I became a zombie now and became friends with Sakura and those guys
If Mr. Yanagi was gone, I would be like that
[music]